hello everyone and welcome to one of the
games that was most requested while i
was on vacation and showing the games
from the magnus carlson invitational
and if you're wondering why i'm wearing
this mask well it's
because i'm just showing it off i
received it yesterday with a letter from
a subscriber
so thank you matthew matthew his wife
made it for me
and i decided to show it to you guys
there it is it's a nice uh
chest themed mask there we have it nice
pieces and everything
so after i'm done recording this video
uh probably going to go to the store
wearing this
bad boy and you know people are going to
be very jealous but
what are you going to do but yeah
getting back to this game
it's a really really awesome game
featuring the greatest opening that
that was ever invented in chess alilah
chess zero versus stockfish
uh they were playing a sort of a match
sort of a
replica of the match stockfish had
against alpha zero
uh i i think it was uh like a hundred
games match and uh
predefined openings uh the usual stuff
so we're gonna discuss the the result
and uh
well some other uh features afterwards
but now let's just uh check out the game
so leela with the white pieces
opens with e4 with e5 from stockfish
knight f3
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 and with
bishop to c5 we have the joko piano
the italian game is on the board and we
reach the position from the thumbnail so
what is the best move in this position
i don't think if you've uh if you've
even been following this channel for a
little bit
uh you know where we are going with this
so for thousands of years people were
wondering what to play here
you know by thousands of years i mean
for a very long time
and then one one man uh one man uh
william davies evans one day said here
we're gonna play b4 and
this shall be known as the evans gambit
now we've never showed it is
there there's this first game first ever
game where the evans gambit was employed
in the game
uh william davis uh evans versus
mcdonald a very famous game uh so i
think that's the game we're going to
show after this one and then we're going
to talk a bit more about
this good gentleman here but yeah like
we said leela goes for b4
and yes the evans gambit is on the board
and one of the reasons why so
many of you requested this uh we have
bishop captures and now
c3 accepting the evans gambit is always
the best
way to play against it we have bishop to
a5 and now d4 so sacrificing some
material
and creating a very very strong center
and hoping to get some very rapid
development
we have d6 in the old days masters would
usually accept all of these pawns and
then
lose terribly we have queen to b3 by
lila now putting pressure on the f7 pawn
and
queen to d7 stockfish defense and now
knight beat the d2
capturing is also possible one of the
moves that is played today
uh but lilac prefers to keep the
attention we have knight bd2 and now
bishop to b6 this is the
uh the usual setup against uh
uh the evans gambit you clear the a5
square for the knight and you want to go
after the bishop and the queen so here
we have d captures on e5 first now
stockfish uh
if if if stockfish wanted you can go 95
first trade some pieces and then go
and then recapture but we have d
captures on e5 instead right away
and now a4 bishop a3 is also possible
very popular move
uh cutting the the black angle from uh
from castling
but first we have a4 here yeah and now
uh they're well there is a game in the
database where knight
the h6 was played but here uh the move
that uh stockfish plays is a new move
and that is knight to a5 and if you just
try to continue developing
and castle it's not that easy if 97 you
no longer guard the f7 pawn
and if knight to f6 then you might run
into bishop to a3
and only then after knight to a5 queen
a2 you can trade captures captures let's
say but still
uh you will need a few moves to
successfully castle with black
so here like we said the stock which
goes for knight to 85 right away and
now we have queen to a2 uh we have queen
to e7
now preparing to shift the queen over to
f6 and then bring the knight over to e7
so the queen from f6 will guard the f7
pawn
bishop to a3 attacking the queen also
slicing through this diagonal
queen to f6 and now we have finally
castles by leela
uh we have knight to e7 and here is
where the
uh well where the fun really starts here
stock which is ready to castle
uh the the bishop pair is fully
operational so we should definitely do
something
and uh well keep the black king in the
center of the board at least for as long
as possible
so here leela does exactly that knight
captures on e5 and now there's a triple
attack on the f7 pawn stoker's just lost
the pawn
so might as well uh pick up the knight
which is what starfish does
we have capture sun e5 and now bishop
captures an f7
with check so keeping the king in the
center of the board king to f8 and now
bishop back to d5 saying i'm not worried
about this since the knight is now
pinned
and yes black is up a piece but uh you
still have to get this rook into the
game you still have to get this rook
into the game the bishop needs to be
developed
and also the knight isn't looking all
that impressive uh
uh on a5 so a lot of things to figure
out for stockfish
we have c6 attacking the bishop and now
first
knight f3 improving the position of the
knight with an attack on the queen
queen to f6 and now uh well now okay
your bishop is under attack however
uh sometimes you should move your piece
when it's attacked sometimes you
shouldn't
maybe this is one of those uh special
cases so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this
deep positional idea leela played in
this position
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredibly deep positional idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
rook 8 to e1 and now it becomes obvious
well there's still this spin
uh with with the bishop from a3 to f8
diagonal and now if you capture the
bishop
simply capture zero opens up the attack
and you don't really have good ways of
defending this for example if bishop
back d6 is coming and now
there's not much to play if knight g6
you can just open up a discovery here
with
check and once you block it it's just
for example queen or
rook delivers checkmate the queen slices
this the the bishop now pins the bishop
there's uh
nothing here it's just checkmate so
danger lurks here so we have h6 stock
which creates some
room for the king uh later on if needed
maybe g5 is is coming
but now e5 also one of the one of the
ideas why rook to
e1 is such a nice move guards the e5
pawn and now the knight can be shifted
over to d4
we have queen to f5 and now first bishop
to e4 getting the bishop out of harm's
way
with a tempo on the queen so queen f7
now offering a queen trade and now queen
to c2
so again ideas like bishop here you you
have to be careful
uh might be might be coming so king to
g8 here black on pins
uh there's no there it could be a bit
dangerous putting your king and queen on
the light square diagonal with white
still having a light square bishop
but these squares are very nicely
covered by black so it's not really an
issue so far
and here leela plays another very very
deep move
uh one not everyone might decide on
uh bishop captures on a knight on e7 and
it seems weird you have the bishop pair
this bishop is just beautiful
giving it up for the knight that
seemingly isn't doing all that much
but alilah leela has has a plan so
bishop captures queen captures and now
knight the d4 saying that okay if if you
trade here further let's say captures
captures i have now
a very strong center this rook still
isn't coming into the game this rook
will take at least two moves again into
the game and
there well it's a very unreasonable to
think that this knight will ever join
the game i mean
how are you planning to get that knight
into the game uh it's possible but you
have to play
uh at least three moves and while that's
happening
you know f4 f5 f6 is coming so here
after knight to d4
we have h5 by stockfish now with ideas
of shifting the rook into the attack via
rook to h6
but now f4 we have bishop to e6
continuing development and now king to
h1 you don't want your king stuck on
this diagonal now the knight
can also move we have bishop to c4
attacking the rook and bishop to d3 now
offering a trait of light square bishop
so we have captures captures and now
rook to f8
so stockfish definitely improved the
position a little bit he got the rook
into the game
next to rook to h6 is coming and you
only need to figure out how to get
this knight into the game so f5 by lila
those pawns are marching forward and now
you have to be careful for example if
you continue with rook to h6 which
seems like a logical next move f6 is
just a game over
i mean you can go for captures knight to
f5 is coming attacking the rook and the
queen
and you just fall apart here so here
stockfish says
f6 and the threat of this knight coming
to f5 is simply too great we must
eliminate this knight so bishop captures
knight
uh we have c captures and now b6 and now
okay
you've eliminated white's uh very strong
knight however you've given up this very
strong bishop here
and now okay you play b6 you free up the
b7 square for your knight but still how
is this
knight coming into the game okay you
might come into the game via the
uh the b7 square but from b7 where where
is the knight going you you can't go
here
whoa that's uh that's a very nice arrow
i didn't know you could also draw
color colorful arrows uh wow that's
that's actually really awesome i did not
know that uh but okay
at least maybe the knight has some way
of entering the game maybe b7 maybe here
maybe f7 and then
something i don't know uh but okay rook
the e3 lila says while you figure that
out i'm just gonna
do a nice rock clip get my rooks into
the game and well
threaten some f6 ideas so rook to h6 and
now
h3 first uh getting rid of any back rank
weaknesses a clearing of the h2 square
for the for the white king we have queen
to d7
uh knight b7 is possible but might be a
bit too slow so first queen to d7
uh with some pressure uh on this on this
f5 pawn
and now rook the g3 now threatening f6
so
black has to move the king king h8 and
now rook f2 f3
so what what is happening here if you
try c5 d5 is coming and then you just
have
three pawns here it's just just crazy so
after rook f2 f3 we have queen to e8 now
saying okay any d5 ideas in the future
then your e5 pawn is hanging
but now queen e3 uh leela now puts
pressure on the rook on h6
f6 will will again be incredibly strong
because if captures then the rook here
will will be hanging
so knight to c4 finally leela allows the
knights to enter the game
but now uh now it's not a problem queen
to f4
again this is coming so rook to f7
uh and now finally f6 but this is what
stockfish decided to do as a defensive
idea
rook the h7 now everything is nicely
defended if you capture this then
captures
everything is nicely defended here and
even if you go for something like czech
king jade and queen captures on h5
white is still posing a lot of problems
but black seems to be surviving here
so instead leela just increases the
tension with rook to g6
so what what what do you play here uh we
have g captures on f6 by stockfish
e captures on f6 and now h4
and now uh black's still up a piece but
not a lot of not a lot of moves are
possible for black here
for example if white can get something
like queen g5 rook f4 rook g4
and rook to g8 that's that's just it and
this f6 pawn is really really
a problem for black so rook to f2
first and now comes b5 and here
it's very hard to find the move for
black for example if you try something
like
uh queen to e1 check king h2 you don't
have a good way of continuing this if
you try something like
let's say bringing the knight into the
game just queen b8 and that's a game
nothing nothing for you to do here this
will just end in checkmate
so after look to f2 we have b5 by
stockfish but this is a last resort move
this is a
a desperado move where i mean you don't
really do anything with this move
leela simply captures it and now you
can't even recapture because if you
recapture
rookie 2 is coming and now again you
cannot capture because of queen to b8
which will follow with the checkmate so
you'd have to move the queen but now
ideas like rookie 6 are coming
and the d5 d6 and so on for example if b
for d5 opens up an attack on the knight
and now you don't have all that much to
do d6 is coming b3 you can go queen to
b4 and
uh well rook here will will be an option
so not not much you can do here knight
c2 attacks the queen queen c3 for
example even
uh and if a5 then just d7 and now this
is the threat
and of course if you capture this then
just check and that's just it
rook g7 can be played and now rook h6
will be checkmate
only one of the lines that shows how
hopeless uh stockfish's position is
so here we have queen to f8 but now just
the b captures on c6 now leela creates a
pass pawn
will be soon a connected pass pawn with
a5 stock which starts pushing the pass
pawn and now queen g5 preparing rook f4
rook g4 and finally
finishing up with rook to g8 so a4
stockfish can just wait and see
what happens and now rook to f4 with the
with the idea that we mentioned
knight to e3 guarding the g4 square and
now even though rook captures an h4 is
enough for leela to win
uh lila now starts uh and lila now just
starts showing off and this is why i
enjoyed this game so much first the
night sacrifice on e5 then the
deeply positional rook the e1 move and
now the
the showing off so rook to e4 now
uh saying okay you move the knight and
then when you move the knight only then
will i play rook to g4
and definitely what what you should do
here but
none of it works for example if this
rook g4 there's no defense against rook
to g8
so stockfish unfortunately doesn't
resign here in the style of old masters
but rather decides to play it on by
playing a3 gives up the knight and
now we will we will have a grind but
which is good for us because we will
have
we will be uh privileged to see uh leela
showing off even more so rook captures
an e3 we have a2
and now rookie one guarding the queening
square we have queen to b8
and now queen to d5 uh putting pressure
on the rooks preparing to push the past
pawns we have rook to f8
and now queen captures an a2 just
eliminating that pawn
queen to d6 and now again d5
now the two connect two two pass pawns
are now connected we have queen c7 and
now queen to b1
uh sorry queen to b1 rook the c8
[Music]
half you have to play something and now
queen to f5 again putting pressure on
the rook preparing f7
so rook to a8 and now rook to g4
we have rook to b8 black just uh needs
to waste moves uh
and now d6 leela can win win this with
with any
uh move order f7 f7 is enough but the
leela now
starts giving up pawns d6 we have queen
captures and
rook the c1 preparing to push the pawn
stalkfish blocks and now
rook to e1 preparing rook to e7 and
such such nice ideas so here if you if
you grab the other pawn as well which
lila is offering then f7 is coming and
after rook f8
anything just wins queen e5 check rook
g7 and this is just checkmate
so instead we have queen to d6 but now
again
rook the e6 attacking the queen queen to
f8 and
now c7 giving up yet another pawn
rook captures and now of course queen e5
threatening f7 with a discovery
uh and now if you block the pawn then it
just captures rook g8 you're gonna go
queen g5 check here and rook to h8 and
that's it uh queen is gonna go here
you're going to play queen
captures with checkmate uh or instead
what happened in the game
rook the b1 check uh stockfish did not
want to resign here as again you know
people would say stockfish are lost in
in 58 moves and instead people will say
stockfish may be lost in 60 something
moves so
king h2 and now rook the h1 checks
stockfish prepares a deep double
double rook sacrifice to prolong the
game a few moves with captures and now
rook to c1 with check king h2 and
rook to h1 again with check king
captures and now
king to h7 waiting for the inevitable
and the inevitable does come
so queen h5 check queen to h6 and now
rook the e7 check king h8 and now of
course uh you'll see it mate in one
queen captures an h6 so really really
incredible stuff stockfish getting
checkmated and even though
the other part of the game wasn't really
all that impressive it was basically
just uh
just a very easy grind for leela as i
call it showing off
but that uh the choose you know playing
the evans gambit sacrificing the knight
and e5 and that rook
8 e1 positional idea brilliant and i i
enjoyed it immensely i hope you did as
well and that you you know
uh that your saturday was at least
slightly improved by this game
so like i said uh that's the game i do
hope you enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank stefan armstrong fernando i asked
anthony jones and aaron ethan barcodian
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the the good stuff
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world but before that we will
probably show the first ever game where
the evans gambit was played
uh and talk a little bit more about the
inventory of the evans gambit
so once again i do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon have an excellent
rest of your saturday